let's get in real quick just just you
know you're dropping a new
project now it's all instrumentals right
yeah all instrumentals no samples i got
a band now
shout out to the soul brothers darrow
yannick
christopher mcbride mano neon
um jermaine holmes marcus machado big
yuki
um the list goes on man you know i
like i'm trying to be one of those great
70s bands like like cool the gang and uh
right it's it's crazy to hear you say
you're putting out an instrumental album
with no samples
yep no samples at all i mean listen
a producer is a producer man you know
you got to be able to make
music too like without the sampling you
know what i'm saying
and these are all my ideas with the band
just playing them over
yeah um why why go the
instrumental route as opposed to i don't
know just you're pete rock you could get
verses from whoever you want you've done
it before
so like why why why just do the full
instrumental route on the
on this go around because i want people
to to really
feel the music without no noise on it
at first you know what i'm saying funny
because that that's what happened with
uh with donuts with dilla it was like
yeah i don't even want to hear anybody
rapping on donuts nope
you just want to press play on it and
just vibe and just vibe because you know
what music is a vibe it's medicine
it's heal it's a healer you know what
i'm saying so
that's my job first is to do that for
the people yeah i mean
and you know you can bring the rappers
in any time i'm ready to do something
like that you know what i'm saying i got
a whole bunch of that coming out soon
with other rappers and with my own team